[Music]
hey folks here we are well it's the
Super Mario podcast happy Halloween
what thank you yeah he's waiting for
that oh yeah Peters all right we are
[ __ ] virgins huh
holy [ __ ] speak for yourself I'd clean
up in Japan right now
Dan soda's with us our boy yeah our boy
for so long we've been tight with him
for so many years this is fun dude
Millions Netflix HBO Comedy Central the
bonfire bonfire
every time you say my credits I gotta
eat it like a coin
who is your go-to in the in the Mario
Kart who's your driver I do like Yoshi
honestly Yoshi's fun Yoshi's my guy I'm
a big I'm a big Mario Kart on the switch
so I love it I was just a little n a for
your boy yeah
today we're doing uh just like a little
simple haunted fruit punch with some uh
nice cherries on there spooky all right
dude I love it yeah this should be funny
is this if you guys planned all this to
get me off the wagon yeah
I don't want you back on the wagon
because I remember you were a beer in a
shot drinker
this is a lovely non-alcoholic drink oh
is tasty well I bet if you put booze in
that it'd be real I have a confession to
make well last I try to get soda on the
bachelor party episode which comes out
next week and uh that was like a year
off my life it killed me partially
because DeRosa every [ __ ] 10 minutes
shots shots so four in the afternoon
we're all on the road so much that I
can't tell when I'm sick anymore because
I just never feel good so I go and feel
them pretty rough but I'm like is it
allergies I don't know but I'm like ah
whatever probably had 10 to 12 drinks
that night easily I mean we went out for
steaks after I mean we easily had that
many and DeRosa even at dinner is a
drink no you're wasted and you know I
went on stage I'm like you know when
you're on straight struggling to
enunciate yeah that was uh that was at
the Comedy Cellar The Late Show that was
one of the shows I realized that it was
time to pack it up oh really I was I got
so drunk at triona's because I never
wanted to see I never wanted SD to see
me drink ah because on Friday nights
you're there for like four spots yeah
triana's is a bar down the street from
seller in the West Village and so I'd go
around the corner and just do shots with
beers and dude I was on stage at the
late show and I was like Pastor I just
couldn't talk yeah I was like damn I
remember when I got into the cellar I
saw Colin Quinn you know hero and I was
like any advice he goes just don't drink
and I was like oh yeah and I had a
whiskey I was like [ __ ] this is bad but
he's right because you get too drunk and
it gets up she keeps going he's like no
observational humor that's kind of lame
yeah saying comedy that's pretty stupid
you know no praise Allah but uh a
bachelor party drinking is a that's a
long that's a marathon we got we did
four hours and I mean the episodes of
Banger next week are coming out but dude
that it set me back so many [ __ ] days
I was in Phoenix last weekend I was
dying I I took a cover test I was
negative but I was doing those shows
where I'm like I'm of like the mentality
if I can perform I'll perform sure but
it was like this that 90s Knicks Patrick
Ewing these in the ice bucket I'm like
I'll power through but holy [ __ ] when
you're at stand up live I was at stand
up live so you can go right to the hotel
after right to the hotel I was with
veter yeah uh and every time I got off
stage I would like collapse they would
hand me NyQuil I just down it you know
it was that level of sick I'm telling
you you yeah that was your Jordan Flu
Game right you have to uh man taking a
week off and I don't even drink and I
take weeks off and I really and I feel
it where I'm like take a week off the
road and you're like all right yeah yeah
I'm watching sober October with these
guys and they're they're all looking
better they look eight years younger
they're all like on the treadmill I'm
like damn maybe I should do that I quit
drinking and everyone was like hey good
for you I quit smoking cigarettes and
everyone was like you look 10 years
younger oh the six I think it was the
cigs that were getting me but man do I
miss those the most they work cigarettes
work the second Putin threatens nuclear
anything I'm buying a pack of cigarettes
he said if he made it to 80 he would are
smoking cigarettes again and he did oh
wow he died very soon after that's
[ __ ] awesome yeah I said 70.
yeah 70 I'm gonna start drinking and
smoking again yeah all right well so I
guess you'll never be drinking and
smoking yeah I don't know we'll see all
right I quit I quit it 29 so I could get
[ __ ] up at 70. there you go but then
your body is a hangover 70s oh take me
to my wife
you're already in a wheelchair probably
yeah you got the IV you got the feedback
you got a Jamaican lady that's going to
give you a hangover here exactly in the
home because being old is basically the
same as hungover it is it's just a life
hangover right you just lived all your
life and then now you're hungover and
you're [ __ ] I'm looking at my
grandma's 94. bad hangover exactly
everything she does she's like where's
my [ __ ] keys that's how you feel on
stage when you're sick you just feel old
I'm not talking slowly my voice isn't
great
hot cities are not easy to be sick in
yeah but your thing you have a great
voice so you never got the Smoky Stevo I
started getting it it started coming
yeah it started getting a little raspy
look at Chappelle he's getting a little
oh yeah the way Dave's like everybody
knows that I am but now it's even
smoking your jail Colvin does it perfect
all right I do I do more Chappelle Show
arrows Chappelle Killing Him Softly Yeah
Dude Killing himselfish belt jail can do
the Smoky one oh wow you gotta
understand man it's just it's pretty
good yeah but Dave's got he's been
smoking for well have you heard Tom
Waits oh my I mean Tom Waits already I
know he came in with a Gruff voice at
like 28 yeah now seismologists have to
say what he's saying
it's like it's rumbling that I'll I'll
decipher piano has been drinking
is he the one who am I thinking of on
he's on Letterman and he's hilarious
he's mad funny he's super quick Tom
Waits yeah Tom Waits rules he's a sexy
guy something about him he's a guy that
yeah he's not like classically he's not
a handsome guy but he's he's got that
he's got it yeah dude he's got some
[ __ ] bangers yeah he's got an hour
and 26 minute clip of him that's more
than most comedians yo if Letterman has
you on that much it means you're [ __ ]
fun right right I think he's got a
couple great lines even this young Tom
Waits he looks older than us yeah
he sounds like if an old house could
talk
you know like in Pixar movies
you don't want to live in me I'm an old
house isn't that the dream I just want
to be on Bob's Burgers and then do stand
up and you'll never work a day in your
life that's it that's where I'm gonna
you do a lot of VoiceOver I do voice
over stuff what have you been doing uh
recently I did Paradise PD on Netflix I
do NFL films top 100. wow I want so I
told the NFL films I've been doing it
for six years I'm like hey when your guy
dies I want the season recap job I want
to be like that year the Raiders knew
that fall would bring you know and then
you hear where they score it yeah yeah I
want that job you could be the next
Attenborough dude I would yeah I would
[ __ ] love just get high and talk
about seagulls
look at this guy yeah the Rhino presents
himself yeah I could watch that [ __ ] all
day yeah there you go pause I go are we
gonna see this rhino [ __ ] yeah it's like
the scrapped ones somebody had a bit
about how like it'd be fun to narrate
like dudes at a bar with Attenborough oh
you know like like picking up a chick
well they kind of did that on Chappelle
Show with when keeping it real goes
wrong they did the NFL films thing I
remember what he's like but he wasn't
there instead it was a yeah we're
keeping it real goes wrong that was a
great one man that Chappelle Show was a
banger
oh hey look Sally's on it oh you know
what it was it was uh Great Moments in
hookup history that was when they did
NFL field uh I did I did a few voices on
10 year old Tom on HBO oh hell yeah
that's a great show that shows I mean
that whole that's like Steve dodarian
rules did you ever watch like life at
times
Jay's obsessed with it and it got me
into it it's very funny yeah I love
nickroll's great yeah it's got a lot lot
of great [ __ ] on there but uh
when you do the voice over with him you
do the script and then you just he's
like all right let's refer for you yeah
you just keep riffing and he's fun to
riff with because that's so he'll just
go in weird directions yeah all right
yeah I always liked um like I remember
when we were all doing mics or whatever
and Bob's Burger came out Bob's Burgers
and Todd Berry did the voice of a cow
wow I was like excited yeah because I
was like we're I was like Todd Berry
that's Todd Berry on the or like you
know Gene merman was like the sun
because it seems so great just to get a
voiceover job I mean did you hear
Michelle wolf got uh the new GTA yeah
get out of the [ __ ] car I'll kill you
that's my car I'm sorry are you comedian
Michelle don't look at my [ __ ] face
I'll execute every [ __ ]
[Laughter]
you need to pull fiction music right
there cool honey bunny yeah
and I'll execute every [ __ ]
I heard I heard Macho Man Randy Savage
that's who I play on Paradise PD I they
like let me do Macho Man on Paradise PD
and they were like at one point they
were like just cut a promo and so they
gave me like things that I was supposed
to say and that was that was the most
fun damn because there I was in like a
big you know a fancy sound booth yeah
with the headphones on and just being
like yeah and another thing so I cut I
cut it as his um as his uh as his ghost
I'll do God bless Mean Gene yeah that
guy was supposed to cream Rises to the
top dude no he's got the purple shirt
already does cream person yeah yeah
they're like Comics they have to build a
Persona dude in the way that he would
like you know he has like little isms
like the way he would go down and pop
yeah and he'd be like yeah I'm telling
you something right now they're annoying
yeah and they were just like my
favorites what my favorite line is when
he goes cup of coffee he starts off with
a coffee and he goes cup of coffee here
coffee in the big time yeah
it's [ __ ] hilarious
only because of him yeah yeah I hated
him when I was a kid because I was such
a big Hulk Hogan fan wow I was such a
macho man guy I don't know why it's
always that it's like his brothers he
just took a giant hit a weed yeah yeah
how do you create that how do you craft
that oh they pulled out of his ass
there's a great interview with his
brother where his brother talks about
like the two guys it's like Comics we're
all influenced by people the wrestlers
are influenced so there was like guys
that worked the territories and his dad
was a professional wrestler so there's
two guys that he liked so when he was
coming up he was like practicing doing
that breathy like right it might it's
not Bruiser Brody but it's like somebody
like that that does like the holding in
your breath like I'm gonna talk like
that and then you just add it in yeah so
then any other origin story of the cream
that he just took it from catering yeah
pretty much they would challenge each
other backstage be like do something
with this and they throw it out oh
really yeah like Freestyle yes yes to
like work yeah
[Music]
I also love that that t-shirt looks like
a short sleeve turtleneck yeah he's so
muscular he's like even a little more
yeah I gotta let the arms out they're
basically like improv yeah savants well
that's what that's why uh like wrestling
kind of sucked for a while because Vince
McMahon controlled their promos oh he
like it was like they what would they do
to us with TV sets right that's what
Vince McMahon did to everybody you can't
[ __ ] with the artist and then they were
like because this is back in the day
this is droids and cocaine dude anytime
you let the performers do what they do
it is gonna be better so that was what
happened with Louie FX right Louie make
it and then everyone was like that's so
genius oh the guy made the thing he
wanted to make exactly and then now
they're like that's what a concept I
know anybody wanted the Louis deal
because this is something that networks
don't like hearing but it's the truth is
there's a lot of people that work there
that really don't do anything of course
us and they feel like they need to do
something yeah so their job is to be
like I think we should change that yep
and if you challenge it you're like
difficult to work with yeah you're like
I don't think that's why I do that I'll
work with people who will like literally
change something and then change it back
in the next paragraph and I'm like
you're just wasting time right this is
crazy they they canceled Family Guy
twice I know and then it's it's been as
big it's just under the Simpsons as far
as how big it's been for Fox right
that's true and it's so great everybody
loves it and it's like the funniest show
I remember when they canceled we were
all in college and you had to get it on
like Morpheus they're like LimeWire yeah
because ah you'd have to go download it
on kazaar that's true holy God the
industry sucks that's why the internet's
winning you [ __ ] come guzzlers but
you know what's funny is then now the
internet's just letting too many people
in now the club now you did the thing
where you're like I'm gonna throw a
party in a field so no one so no one
gets Uninvited and then everyone showed
up and you're like you should have got a
bouncer for this thing but Gatekeepers
did have some merits they had too much
power too much power but some Merit but
they were keeping some real [ __ ] bags
out yeah we just need the little thing
you put when you have a toddler in the
doorway we need like just a little bit
if you can figure out how to lift it off
you should come in it's a little knob
thing yeah but yeah now it's it's like
no gate at all and like you know
Chappelle I love Chappelle but I I don't
the ReUse a gate the race the recent
stuff I'm like Dave what are we doing
yeah I know right I'm gonna sit on stage
and read my tax returns I know now this
is going by how I filed it by State yeah
part of me is like maybe I'll stab yeah
yeah maybe I'll go up there
that guy was just yelling structure
that's what he was yelling at Dave
he's like he was a man I think I loved
him he's like I preferred your earlier
stuff I loved when you had a clear
premise on a bit
dude I thought it was funny when
mullaney had Chappelle do a set and
everyone got mad at mullaney you're like
you're seeing two of the greatest
comedians of all time I know on the same
bill and you're upset about it yeah in
Ohio think how that would have played in
Portland Oregon
City holy [ __ ] it also would have been
funny if mullaney just did Super
anti-trans and stuff the whole he just
went up there he goes you know what I
don't understand
well what are you
are you a he or a [ __ ]
yeah I was gonna say
they got a new pod coming out what is it
Peters we need we need one for it we
need one get us
gonna be way more liberal with these
there we go
Mario that was a red shell you threw it
just then oh yeah we were talking about
Mario Kart though I played it on switch
oh you know what we were crazy I was
playing with Mateo on switch once and
he's so good at the game and he's like
keeping rules from us that you have to
like you know hit that R yeah the power
slide I [ __ ] I'm like dude of course
you're keeping rules from us got to be
transparent I gotta be transparent you
gotta know about you also when you jump
off jumps you get a boost yeah whoa I
didn't know any of this [ __ ] for 20
years I didn't know that that's a new
rule though isn't it yeah it's just you
know oh okay how about that Rainbow Land
that's trippy dude I love it I love it
it's that's it's Mario Kart to me
signifies the end of a two-show night
when I'm just like eating candy in my
hotel oh yeah just laying there and I'm
like damn dude I'm a child yeah playing
Mario Kart well that blew my mind I
think I worked with Nate once and he had
like uh him in a big J at NBA Jam oh
yeah I didn't know we could do this it
felt like overload of too much fun
comedy boo video games you just get all
the stuff you wanted yeah I think Jay
and I were both once in Indianapolis we
were both playing the uh different
crackers clubs yeah and uh yeah it was
not great but uh Jay brought his Xbox
and we're just playing NBA 2K oh I'm
like this is dude why does does everyone
do this yeah Peter and I used to we
worked Comedy on State one year we were
doing Valentine's Day so they did three
shows in the night and we're in between
shows we'd go back and play a game to
NBA 2K and then by the time we got back
to the club it was satin like ready to
go yeah it was awesome it was like you
just reloaded it you're like all right
reload reload it was so fun I wonder if
comics in the 60s are like we got
Scrabble
Jenga bro Shoots and Ladders but you
know what's funny is there is a part I
read in Bill hicks's biography where
they said that when Nintendo came out he
bought a Nintendo and he was sober in
that like him playing him playing Mario
Brothers was like a big deal I wouldn't
have survived in the 80s we would have
all been dead the blow alone in the and
the lack of yeah
that's my heart at a [ __ ] you know
Side Splitters but here's what because
of all the drugs the comedy bar was so
much lower like have you ever seen clips
of like Richard Belzer in the 80s he was
a crowd work genius and you see the clip
and I'm like I don't even know what he's
talking about look at this homo
yeah look at you they're just saying
words that you're like well that would
end my career right now yeah my favorite
is on that Paul provenza Green Room I
used to love that show when uh Stan
hopes talking about his book yes and
then Belzer goes like what is this I
forget what stand-up's talking about but
he's talking about something that bills
he goes what is this what do you what
are you selling a thing and then stand
up Chris Pelzer I bought your book yeah
yeah so good I loved it he's called him
out yeah well it's it's old hack versus
hilarious guys in their Prime he is good
on Law and Order SVU all right well he's
good at that drama show
we gotta get out that show by the way
what the hell yeah Colin Quinn's got
that bit about our favorite he's a New
Yorker and he's like he's like the only
New Yorker that hasn't been asked on Law
and Order to SVU he's like he's like I
have stumbled onto the set by accident
multiple times I love that bit anytime
he goes that bit because then he does
what he thinks his Law and Order episode
would be oh so good you know you
mentioned Nintendo with Bill Hicks
Nintendo should Market as like hey hey
quit drinking this is healthier yeah
that's a great little uh way to sell
more units damn because it really yeah
you're absolutely correct that that
would be a way for alcoholics to be like
hey I can go play Zelda or not ruin my
family exactly yeah but drinking on the
road is fun oh it's it's it's sad now
that it's almost pavlovian like I get
into the club I have tequila on my rider
so I don't have to wait for a waitress
that's how bad of a boost that's the
problem yeah that's a problem like I
don't want to wait for eight minutes for
this uh Obama three to bring me a
tequila soda I need it right now yeah so
I make it right when I get there and I'm
like all right I'm back do you have
specific tequila
I've been
this is gonna get ugly why
I'm out with casamigos what I'm out what
happened well I've been I've been
reading all about Tequilas because I'm
trying to if I'm gonna drink this much
I'm trying to stay somewhat healthy it's
I hate to do this and out these these
these Clooney's of the world but no he's
not with it anymore it's full of garbage
it's all yaked up with all kinds of [ __ ]
it's stepped on
events and additives and all this [ __ ]
really tear them out all the way no not
terrible the Rocks yeah rocks it's
pretty good I'm doing I'm doing research
here on like what's better for you you
know it's all poison at the end of the
day it does make sense that the Rocks
it's cleaner it's cleaner yeah give it a
[ __ ] I'm telling you there Toadstool I
don't know I don't know why we're
plugging the rock stick heel on here he
doesn't need more press no he's doing
okay well what's funny is I that Mexican
restaurant I used to work at they made
us get certified in Tequila oh wow so
you know a lot about tequila I did I
don't think
Vince Neil came in oh the Cabo Wabo he
has like Trace Rios oh sorry I'm
thinking a Sammy Hagar yeah that's Cabo
Wabo yeah every celebrity has a tequila
yeah it's crazy it's like a podcast with
comedians yes you're famous you have to
[ __ ] sweet you have to have a tequila
and we have a whisper yourself
in the game [ __ ] but he but he
was like you got guys have Trace it's
Trace Rios right
he asked for his own tequila yeah what
is a real and then he got drunk on the
cafe and his I just kept looking at how
his face looked
Now look for a tracer I can't tell if
that's really cool or really sad to get
drunk on your own I'll tell you the
Tequila that I love the most yeah but
they should but we do it like with it in
the studio
[Music]
that's weird
yeah dude tripartita partita partita's
okay that's the [ __ ] that I would like
you think Guy Fieri shows up to his
restaurant he's like garbage nachos now
yeah need them
any restaurant he eats at yeah he should
have a hot sauce holster wouldn't that
be fun or if he had it on his shoulders
you guys want me you guys want some
awesome sauce
that would be fun every [ __ ] every
famous person has a tequila partia
partita yeah the breaking bad guys
the one that uh I mean this is like 12
years ago Jesse Pinkman and uh Walter
White have it oh really jeez that's a
good way to stay in touch I should have
I should have done I'm gonna do uh a rum
for my dead father that's my liquor I'm
gonna do a rum because that's what
killed Gary what are you running what do
you want it's got to be what are you
running from
that'll probably be the tag yes yes
I might call it uh hidden rums good or
every other weekend drum
yeah that's good partial what could you
call it uh Panic rum yeah that's that's
a negative or you could call it child
support
I'm trying to get more into court lingo
right right you're not my real rum
that was a big reason you quit right
no what no what what was that my dad was
out yeah no I quit because I loved doing
comedy yeah and I just like was like oh
I'm gonna be one of those guys where if
I drink
like right now I'll be I would have been
living in like Syracuse with a lady I
got pregnant right drinking and being
like Sam and Mark
they're so [ __ ] great ah [ __ ] we're
not at least it's just the same show as
a time you were a fun drunk you got the
weed yeah that's what you were that's
the thing a lot of fun drunks don't quit
and you were a good you were never bad
vibes ever they started getting like I
started getting a little chippy really
yeah I started getting a little chippy
never around me
I just get chippy with people I didn't
really like and started coming out and
then I was like I should probably smoke
weed wow because I was smoking weed
already right because I started with
weed booze came in and then booze came
out well I watched fist fights online
probably too much yeah and it's all
booze fueled yeah there's not anybody at
a library like let's go I got some I got
some great Twitter follows for you oh
please faked fights rules baked fights
okay is that High people fighting no
it's just wild [ __ ] and fights it's
just people making pie yeah it's on
Twitter baked fights I uh it's in
Twitter you know there's no limits no no
no like Instagram they edit yeah yeah
the porn on Twitter I can that's pretty
crazy that's pretty crazy if you have
follow any porn things and then you're
just scrolling and you're like whoa that
lady stuck in a baby's eyes she's
getting [ __ ] all right under Sam
plugging his dates I know yeah you look
at it and you're like this is too much
for the grocery store
so clever oh you're on an airplane
they'll put some uh some um nudity in
Airplane movies by the way they are oh
yeah there's a lot of movies with
Trinity I was flying to London to do
shows at the Soho theater and I watched
Jackass 3 or jackass forever and it was
like the screen was so bright and it's
just Stevo being like I've
like this whole dick is covered and he's
like oh no it was just this old British
lady sitting next to me being like where
do you want
[Laughter]
[Music]
but uh he's uh you know that scene where
he's like spacely she makes a mistake
and he keeps circling the mistakes he's
like spanking her oh yeah bent over he
like jerks off I'm pretty hot wait
that's the movie did you guys see the
Army Hammer documentary House of hammer
on Discovery plus that's the movie he
would make every girl watch before he
would start cheese like as he was it's a
pretty good movie it's auditioning it's
Maggie Gyllenhaal right yeah she's
greatness yeah dude that's funny because
Dahmer made you watch Exorcist three not
even a good one what make women watch
Weekend At Bernies too I make him watch
comedian the document
and I go doesn't Colin give good advice
I just re-watched that so that was an
old bit of mine that never worked it was
a it was this never ever worked it was
like you know I always invite women back
to watch a movie and that here's my
here's my trick I only have shitty
movies is it like before streamers I'm
like face off or weak into Bernie's
which one yeah that's good and she's
like all right I'll [ __ ] you fine you
know it's a Sophie's Choice
it's like I'll just [ __ ] you to get out
of these movies yeah right Netflix and
chill that was before Netflix and chill
oh yeah that was it's weird you have to
say something to a woman you can't just
be like let's go have sex sometimes you
can now some women I think you could
just say it too I don't know I've tried
it Blockbuster and bus oh that's good
that's pretty good that's not bad all
right all right you look like you have a
big brain with that hair yeah
why things with your mind
damn these sounds he sounds like
yeah she should lose this luster though
just hit him earlier just in case
now it's warm what else do we have give
us another one you gotta hit it hard oh
I like it right that's a good one that's
the one up dude let's see if I can guess
him I'm gonna shut my eyes
I mean we know that That's a classic I
love that theme song oh it's classic
death yep yep
[Laughter]
yeah is that through a tube uh no it
says Mario oof [ __ ] oh we got hit
[Music]
what else you got
Bachelor tube that's my favorite yeah
[ __ ] you're good that's all a star you
got a star yeah oh that was such a happy
temporary gold coin obviously death
oh it is death
all right I'm switching to Super Mario
Bros
I can hear the vaginas drying
we're losing all over it'd be funny if
it's just like super Italian-American
views who's like the election was stolen
[Music]
I think oh wow do you think Italians
like Mario or hate I love them really
you gotta love them boys
the movie was terrible remember John
Leguizamo Dennis
pure money grab for Dennis Hopper yeah
that's Koopa now they got a now they got
the new one coming out with Chris Pratt
even do the Mario voice oh these guys
like hey I'm Mario oh that's a appalling
hey I'm a plumber oh I give him [ __ ] for
that too I think it would be funny if
someone online tries to say that Mario
Brothers is Union propaganda
he would have been like a perfect Mario
he's not he's too handsome no but it's a
voiceover Chris oh it's animated yeah
I'm an idiotics a handsome guy oh he's
handsome but I thought it was real you
know motion picture did you steal the
prince
oh now that you do that it might be too
much Mario
oh wow yeah this is it you gotta do the
voice he is an epic it's an epic
character oh yeah if you need a guy
being like is it me yeah but he's he's
Japanese right that's where it's made I
mean Nintendo's Japanese so it's funny
to think that it's it's Japanese people
being racist towards the town that's
what I'm saying what a fun more yeah
yeah look at that this is an
Italian-American declaration League I
made character
that's like what they tell there's so
many levels of racism oh it's a sandwich
dude good luck come find me in this
casserole but I think he's so likable
any of the sound effects you can't hate
him you can't you can't find racism I
just love the idea that that's what
Japanese parents told their kids they
would be if they didn't do well you
would be a Japanese you would be Italian
primer
I will not father I will do better well
that's why there's a dragon in it
because that's where the Japan comes in
yeah
some of this old video game [ __ ] you're
like yeah this is if you're a dad our
age and you take your kid you're at
least like all right well this is my
childhood this is my [ __ ] but that's
what's weird now is so much [ __ ] is made
for when we were kids that were like
forcing kids remember how we used to
make our parents watch us play video
games yep you're like watch me play this
and they're like I don't I don't give
dude I lived in the 60s right and then
now we do that but with our kids yeah
we're like hey watch it then they're
like ah right the amount of Technology
now is like it's insane like because now
if it just doesn't work immediately I'm
like what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] that's
how dependent you are on right through
that Louis bit that's the classic [ __ ]
the Wi-Fi yeah give it a second yeah I
was I was in the uh I was in the deli
the other day and I'm like I'm so used
to just you're just used to it working
so when it doesn't work you don't even
think so I put my I was listening to an
audiobook on movies in like the 60s and
I put my headset in and it doesn't
connect I didn't even realize it didn't
connect and I [ __ ] you not the part it
doesn't connect for is some editor for
Sam Peck and PAW and uh and Robert
Altman movies and he goes you know what
the difference between Peck and PAW and
uh Robert Altman is pecking pie is a
prick and Robert Altman's a [ __ ] wow I
just had people in the store hear that
live really yeah that's [ __ ]
hilarious but it was a fight it was I
was like this is the perfect line yeah
just one guy no one paid attention no
one like gives a [ __ ] one guy's signing
it and don't look up he goes he's not
wrong
that was a grip on the Wild Bunch yeah
yeah dude it's like uh if it doesn't if
my internet doesn't work on my phone I
get like Huffy I get crazy and it's
gotten worse yeah of course yeah you
expect it it's weird somebody uh Neil
deGrasse Tyson had a great point he was
watching a horror movie with his kid his
kid's like five and you know he's
running from the monster gets in the car
and it doesn't start and he's like Dad
why didn't the car start and he's like
oh cars used to not start sometimes yeah
getting like a Prius and it just
yeah connecting yeah so we're just so
used to things working perfectly it's
crazy how quickly technology goes to
where you'll see you'll be watching a
like a movie or show from four years ago
and you're like that's like an old
iPhone what the [ __ ] is that oh yeah
those cameras are Jay brought it up on
the bonfire recently he's like you look
at sports highlights from like 1994. oh
my good shitty camera so grainy I
remember the first HD camera or the
first HD TV I saw I was at College this
rich kid had one and I walked in he's
watching sports center I was like Jesus
this is [ __ ] crazy looking it will
[ __ ] us though because like it looks
great now but it's gonna keep going and
you're gonna be like you're gonna be on
TV doing a set and you're like look at
that [ __ ] scar from 1988 look at that
mole you'll be able to see everything
every yellow you know the makeup will
keep getting better too Ah that's a good
point true I don't know that is true but
it'll be crazy to when we watch our old
sets oh look how grainy it's kind of
cool that we have them though that we
have set them before [ __ ] looked really
good I got tapes oh my God I have a mini
DVD do you think it's harder for kids of
this generation to watch like a movie
from the 60s
oh yeah I think it was hard in the way
that it was hard for us to watch stuff
from the 70s but I love that [ __ ] I love
though yeah Mark and I are obsessed or
maybe they are moving maybe they will
yeah maybe they'll love [ __ ] because the
90s are coming back around again now
that's true but the difference when we
watched you know Raging Bull or whatever
the hell from the 70s you didn't have 8
million zillion things coming at you
that day from the from the present you
know like new movies came out but it
wasn't like this Onslaught well people I
think people want to watch good [ __ ]
less because they just want to go home
and space out they're like oh I'll throw
something on I'll scroll Tick Tock wow
so you don't want to watch something
that's like real if you want to watch
something well made you really have to
just shut off and people don't want to
focus yeah you got to focus yeah
focusing's shut off everything I mean
not sure if you show yourself kill
yourself
but it will be like it
[Music]
Jesus Christ man that you ran out of
continues oh oh nice Paul I think I'm
pretty sure somebody had no father yeah
someone was raised by video games it is
it's so hard to turn when you turn
everything off now you feel like a
Tibetan monk yeah yeah look at me
disconnected I know my phone's in the
other room I'm like God I'm so present
and you have to let everybody know you
have to go back look at me I better
tweet that I'm not gonna be eating
myself I watch a foreign film now I feel
like I just did three years in a [ __ ]
Monastery or something it's incredible
it's so Intel reading a book reading an
actual book like a paper book it's I do
it before bed and it [ __ ] is great
because you can't help it you can't I
can't fall sometimes I'll watch a funny
show before bed to watch something light
but like if you read a book before bed
you just it's so much easier to sleep
yeah it's true if I watch a show I do
blue light glasses because we sound so
[ __ ] old yeah which is so sad we just
lost everyone
my prescribed nasal spray yeah
yeah you know what I'm in my reference
please sleep apnea
everybody my wreck is a prunes
prune guy you know for me Viagra I love
getting old dudes you guys like Velveeta
cookies oh so much cookies with nothing
else yeah just well big my goodness no
my grandparents would eat snack Wells
that was the greatest they were trying
to stay fit and they couldn't give up
dessert that was big I took down snack
Wells
I my mom was always dieting so I always
had Weight Watchers or snack well snacks
they were worse for you by the way way
more sugar they said less calories I
would have uh Weight Watchers
fudgesicles
they were good yeah that sounds like I
mean look it's not horrible but it was
it wasn't it you have an Oreo after one
of those you're like this is dog [ __ ] I
know I know it's like heroin
back to the reading thing there was
literally a Instagram page called hot
guys reading and they'd show a guy on
the subway reading a book that's how
like rare it is that it's like oh look
at this hunger yeah he's smart he can
read dude Hawkeye's reading let's check
out Hawkeye's reading I don't know if
it's still around but it's got to be
Paige girls just flicking their being
the thoughtful dudes there it is be
great if they're just reading dumb [ __ ]
too he's like just he's a book R.L Stein
what the hell he's reading the pickup
artist
also shows the difference between men
and women you know we're like let's look
at these hot chicks flicking their their
[ __ ] yeah and they're like hey look
at these guys with books
that is hilarious oh it is it's just
hunks reading yeah
wow wow wow
this is insane that's how rare it is to
read
also you get really nervous that you're
gonna click on a picture and like see
your girlfriend being like how do you
feel about people just taking photos of
strangers on the train I do swear it's
it's pretty weird people have gotten too
comfortable with it second one of you no
just anyone just taking photos of
strangers on the train it's a weird move
it is weird you can't get caught that's
for sure oh you've gotten caught taking
a picture or something oh yeah yeah
really what are you gonna do with that
what what's that what are you wait
delete that okay or are you just like
the way you acted off or you go oh it's
uh yes
could you try to shoot it down here and
then dude I'm sorry I was gonna say you
look like a skinny Mario Batali
uh I just want to make my girlfriend wet
so I had to take this picture right
right
by the way pull out that uh candy
ranking William let me let me kick a
potato chip first
oh
what the hell what a spooky surprise
no
no honey White's body oh man luckily I'm
a necrophiliac
it's a victimless crime ah it is it's
really just you know it's no calories
hurt in my head all right so we're
ranking some candies what are we
starting with you right this is right
here
the ones in the bag oh in the bag yeah
dude you guys are coming to a hammy Emmy
a Reese's just so I can eat it you guys
are coming to the right guy all right so
so we have to guess and then move on
give me that one just pick whatever you
want because take five what you're
holding in your right hand
go ahead and put it at number one no I
don't even need to see what this is
going to be my committee
so good
if Koopa and [ __ ] Yoshi can agree
we are two different types of dragons
he's he's Sunni Dragon I'm Shiite easy
man you ready Ray Rice
okay something about a Three Musketeer
I'm gonna tell you something I'm already
putting this [ __ ] last yeah thank you my
shitty half Uncle likes that you have to
try this throw it out the window I'm
gonna tell you right now Three
Musketeers here's what you want to do
uh-oh it's like feeling for avocados
when you go to a when you go to a gas
station and you feel a Three Musketeer
give it a little push that is make sure
hot-headed thing I've never heard anyone
for sure make sure it dents a little bit
and then you got yourself a good Three
Musketeer good call good call I'm taking
this one home that's a soft
not a top five
I think Snickers is up here in the top
three it's a top five for sure I know
it's uh there's a a bar called top five
in there really yeah take five sorry
take five this is five all right take
five is excellent take five is in the
top five I would go ahead and put it
first but all right let's we'll vote on
this but what is it take five Heyday I
don't even know why this is here every
candy bar you can imagine in one floor
is more the hermaphrodite yeah it's like
it's got both dude you could suck [ __ ]
you can do whatever you want yeah payday
oh I do payday is the candy bar that is
left last in a vending machine yeah I'm
a big Twix guy Dude Love Twix Twix to me
is easily top five of course now we
gotta get into it Sour Patch oh they're
Classics and I'm gonna say this so it's
permanently on record I had an
ex-girlfriend teach me that if you take
Sour Patch Kids and dump it into popcorn
at the movies it's delicious since then
Louis J Gomez has said that it's his
that he created it's not I can give you
the woman's name address and phone
number and she's the one that told me
back in 2015. that's an amazing
Discovery it's so good if you just don't
Sour Patch Kids in popcorn and mix it up
I do chocolate in there but I've never
done the Sour Patch Kids too much that's
like a speed ball I can't handle that
you'll love it I don't really I did it
during topics
follow me this is like in a recovery
meeting you're like sometimes when I
want to get a fix you guys brought me in
right you brought me in for the candy
episode
Twix is a [ __ ] just so it's I mean
that's a tough I love Twix stickers
damn I don't want to disrespect that
these are the ones we're ranking right
kitkats garbage it's not garbage why
don't you garbage but it's not great I
mean first off 100 Grand you forget
these things they're bangers oh we're
gonna get a good one in the middle we're
gonna lose a foot on this app
unbelievable hey folks we might be drunk
It's brought to you by diet smoke we're
gonna take a break and tell you guys
about diet smoke and it's the solution
to avoid the oh [ __ ] I'm way too high
moments spin there tight smoke makes
Delta eight THC Delta 9 THC and CBD
products that are perfectly balanced the
gummies drinks Vapes are delicious
they're guaranteed to give you a
beautiful Buzz you've been looking for
without melting into your couch the
exact they extract the THC and CBD from
American grown hemp and shipped directly
to your door no prescription no sketchy
weed dealer no need to leave the house
diet smoke just released a bunch of new
products and flavors no matter what type
of mood you're in they got you covered
if you're ready for that perfect high
head over to dietsmoke.com use code
drunk for 20 off your entire purchase
must be 21 on to order an older to order
now back to the show love you diet smoke
hell yeah
yeah summer is starting to wind down and
I am busier than ever that's why I'm
saving for saving time with factor
factor is ready to eat meals delivered
to your house they make it easy to stay
on top of your schedule while still
sticking to your goals with factor a
quick lunch or a fully prepared dinner
is just two minutes away these heat and
eat meals are a lifesaver when you have
no free time in fact there's new Protein
Plus preference makes it easy to power
up with deliciously satisfying meals and
at least 30 grams of protein per serving
Factor offers 30 meals a week change
your order up every week choose 4 to 18
per week pause or reschedule your
deliveries anytime the chef crafted
recipes are packed with restaurant
quality flavor and everything is
dietitian approved wow stop spending
your precious hours at the store and in
the kitchen let Factor deliver
ready-made meals right to your door each
factor meal arrives prepared
pre-prepared by by their team of chefs
they are ready to heat and eat in two
minutes
they offer vegan veggie Protein Plus
keto and calorie smart options plus cold
pressed juices smoothies energy bites
extra protein veggie sides and more I
had these they're great I love those
smoothies no the killer go dot
factor75.com
drunk 130. you drunk 130
to get 135 bucks off six boxes that's
code drunk 130 at
code.factor75.com all right I hope I got
that right yeah it's
code.factor75.com drunk 130. thank you
I don't like Twix I know I know I'm in
the minority well I don't like them what
I don't like the crunchy wafery [ __ ]
you feel like crunch no it's crunch with
caramel and chocolate and hard food
I put Twix 100 is good but you got to
put Twix ahead give me that 100 Grand I
I took a bite you got to go the other
way this is very underrated
this right here in M M's could sneak
into the top three
it's that good yeah top three peanut M
M's is a [ __ ] classic and I like that
you can keep picking at it I like that
let me go hard they go hard in the paint
we'll have a pain in Eminem all right
all right right now are we all more
chocolate than gummy yeah I mean I love
Swedish Fish
you want to get into it Swedish Fish
[ __ ] rule over Sour Patch oh no way
but then you're also stuck picking them
them out of your teeth for the next few
hours
feelings you're [ __ ] with Swedish Fish
Sour Patch Kids are here's the deal Sour
Patch Kids
Swedish Fish are hairs they're [ __ ]
dude these are Classics I mean you can't
go wrong with a peanut m m this is
heroin Swedish fish is heroin gets
sticky sometimes it's hard to use really
in a pinch Sour Patch Kids fentanyl
it's just a little bit harmless but it's
hot packing we're gonna get a lot of
sugar you're gonna get [ __ ] nuts on
this
keep those away from deeply are better
than the classic the watermelon Sour
Patch Kids yeah oh yeah this is this is
that Chinese fentanyl yeah
that's not for me your boy's about to
get some [ __ ] diarrhea oh yeah you
ready I can't wait to take unnecessary
yeah dude hit me with one shoot it up
dude come on sugar all over your keys
ready
I'm not
oh hold on let me see if I can
oh
come on man that was close that was an
inch an inch away okay right now we got
it again
[Music]
[Applause]
wow if that would have gone in I would
have blown all of you
these are [ __ ] phenomenal all right
well we got it we gotta we got it might
be a head watermelon might be a heter
regular get them away from me I'm just
gonna start it off all right I'll try
get him away from me who are you my aunt
we're gonna start with this payday
direct deposit take five gotta share
Starburst respect absolutely take five
put take five at one this is this is
heroin or fentanyl that's [ __ ] good
dude that's fentanyl I'm telling you in
popcorn don't listen to Louis J Gomez
all right he's killed that woman okay
okay but dude you gave me so many
options here so the Reese's big cup are
we are we doing the big cup or just
regular just regularly I think we gotta
go regular because now we're getting
regular Reese's Pieces here's here's the
stoner secret you freeze them yeah no no
no no frozen Candy out there period
Charleston's shoes in the mix though by
the way I'm twitching out I'm not well
I'm like Michael J over here I I live
off sugar really you look good oh no
it's with the shirt off it's a mess
really yeah I feel like a 50s movies
oh my God I'm just a bowl of pudding
hello Michael Cain and Alfie and pull up
and after that pull up Jimmy Stewart
rear window shirtless you're like this
is the [ __ ] leading man it is before
tybo for sure oh my god dude
I've got the sloppiest body I love you
you've never seen remember sisters yeah
that bow made me think of you
this is young Michael Caine getting shot
oh this is what he was supposed to be
he's a sex symbol have you seen his wife
no she's hot yeah still yeah yeah she's
a higher yeah
that's why Whitey doesn't age
Jimmy Stewart is shirtless shirtless I
mean you could probably just get a
picture too yeah yeah you're going
you're on YouTube that's no good you got
to go GOOG
all right all right what are we missing
all right so I'm gonna tell you okay
kitkat's pretty good
yeah they're probably not right all
right [ __ ] off dude too salty you got to
show something top five I agree it's got
it agreed let's put it at five ah is
that too high just to stop oh I like it
higher but well we gotta we can move
it's velcro all right I'll tell you what
boy let's put it in a four put Kit Kat
at five because I think everyone besides
Norman will I'll let you have it I'll
let you have it it doesn't like KitKat
but we can all agree we need Snickers on
top three
let's do Snickers at two today we're
making trades here
guys you think over the bottom like a
gay I don't even see a Snickers here
it's right there right in front of you
right on top of the sour patch there you
go three yeah put it at two because it's
such a classic it's a classic can't go
wrong it's got everything in it Snicker
please
all right I say 100 I say 100 Grand
Eminem
I I put them at three four five get out
of here I want to bump Kit Kat out all
right bump Kit Kat down to six yeah
we're talking
thank you where you been my whole life
all right all right John candy Starburst
dude uh oh you know what I'd say put
Starburst at one you know oh what are
you crazy I love Starbursts wait can I
follow up with that what flavor all the
colors now you're breaking down
into artificial cherry flavor I don't
know why but the red so Reds are great I
just say you're holding you're throwing
the whole pack up there that's what I
mean
this is all Christmas yeah sugar get it
you know how much sugar is in alcohol
though oh really when I quit drinking
I'll I didn't drink for a month I mean
obviously lost 40 pounds wow because I'm
feeling whiskey and beer wow whiskey you
think Whiskey's just no it's all sugar
Cowboy your beloved take five I don't
know where that goes Taco's number one
it's the best candy bar what about Twix
you would back that up absolutely
and take five is so underrated too like
nobody gets it for sure it would be a
sleeper upset okay how about I mean
where do we put the the watermelon Sour
Patch because it's got to Eclipse they
can't yes suck my dick keeps getting
pushed give me a break
[Laughter]
they make kitkats out of all Starbursts
they do people are going to be furious
people are gonna be furious about this
Starburst dish well you know what
Starburst you had enough he had jelly
beans you had your gummies you've been
out here [ __ ] around on us good point
so you get seven really is that we might
we might heaters we're gonna need a
producer way let me throw this out let
me throw this at you
take that's rough I think that's a tough
I agree with him but we're we're men you
got your children all right now now let
me say this though Reese's has two
things in the top four major is good at
business baby if we had pieces that was
awesome on there too really I love
Reese's Pieces I'm just saying I'm
willing to move Reese's you know because
you have a number one already do you
know what's the most fat [ __ ]
Stoner thing that I do that I used to do
when I exercised regularly before the
pandemic I'd get a pint of Plenty double
double dark chocolate oh that's the good
stuff and then I would have a bag of
Reese's Pieces and then as I ate in the
talenti I would toss them that sounds
[ __ ] good
this is good
yeah do it anymore
that's some high-end Bodega [ __ ] yes it
really everything else is like whatever
and then you get to the talente and
you're like dude shout out Seafood in
Queens that's gotta be what eight
dollars for that pint 8.99
for ice cream are you out of your mind
yeah holy [ __ ] good [ __ ] though dude
good shits that gelato gelato is [ __ ]
nice it is it's it's ice cream with a
college degree
if you get ice cream out of a [ __ ]
paper thing that's a GED yeah and then
it's got a top that's a high school
diploma right and then if it's glass and
you can turn it off dude that's that
thing went to Ivy League yeah I used to
do I used to do a bit about biscotti
that's like the other chips ahoy's
regular cookie and biscotti I studied
abroad
same with panini
[Laughter]
something about the smushed sandwich
they're all hot it's oh it's like a
[ __ ] it's like a face smashed into a
couch it's great
we all got boners that was the boner
okay I mean I think yeah I agree that
payday and Good and Plenty or don't even
get out of here good good night I'm not
high in Swedish Fish either yeah I
didn't fight in Vietnam get out of here
Good and Plenty
I didn't travel up the Nang River yeah
can we get some CCR playing yeah Nixon
ate Good and Plenty I'll tell you they
call you a baby killer
lucky now
hey there you go all right
all right over over I I don't I think
kitkats ahead of Three Musketeers crazy
Three Musketeers Three Musketeers is
here it is when it's soft
it's great unlike a dick that's the
opposite of a dick yeah you want a soft
Three Musketeers
cup yeah there you go yeah okay
[ __ ] yeah
that Snickers vein that made the rounds
I'm a size queen so give me a bit
you like big tits or also have you seen
the ones where they shove the Reese's
Pieces into it the DP of candy oh no
they put Reese's Pieces into oh yeah
I've seen it all right what is that Mr
Marcus no it's just disrespectful to put
100 Grand in 10 though yes no it's not I
say put it at 10. it's KitKat 10 well
here's the thing let's put them up on
the board and then we'll move them
around all right but Three Musketeers at
eight I feel like there's a solid move
sodas I guess we gotta honor our guests
but we can move it around are you
hearing this moms when your kids
this is the
the thing I mean this is is this what do
you think of this list I think KitKat
here's the thing about Norman swayed my
vote on kicking all right you really
made me see that it's kind of a [ __ ]
candy I don't think it is not there's
Wafers let's have this conversation
cheap [ __ ] I love Wafers though yeah a
good vanilla chocolate wafer the real
wafer [ __ ] if it's Harry Harry Spears
he's making little kids oil their feet
or whatever
I like a dessert that can do a DMX
impression I like I like it yeah I love
the candy that does 90 minutes on a
Wednesday
no kids going to his house
or he's got the best candy
he's got Godiva
is that a sales joke uh
holy [ __ ] Halloween is the Super Bowl
for pedophiles
yeah dude Swedish Fish didn't make the
cut and I'm okay with it I think it's
overrated Good and Plenty is it doesn't
even belong
yeah yeah yeah that's putting bunnies
that's like uh you give it to prisoners
that's like college loans
it's a candy that our parents generation
gave us that's just a burden right he
thinks Boomer yeah it's poop that's
Boomers let's all try one just to see
what's up all right let's have some
Boomer fuel Boomer sounds like a candy
it does yeah let's go to the Good and
Plenty it looks like medicine yeah
it probably was it tastes like medicine
it's liquor it's isn't it black licorice
oh that's too many sorry I actually
don't hate it
it's the weapon it doesn't really does
it really does look like it's not
valuable with my good employment but
it's bad Liquors honey my penis works
all the time
how do we not get Twizzlers on here
those are classics
it's better than I thought it would be
but it's not it's not on the list
I like it
yeah it feels like I'm chewing Road tar
the Scandinavians love [ __ ] black
licorice oh they have no souls
gravity these shower curled up here that
we must eat for licorice yeah you've
been Ikea yeah okay here's my only issue
now Starburst has a whole bunch of
flavors we're going one one flavor yeah
but Sour Patch I think represents the
brand all right interesting round over
there we do have a bonus slot Swedish
Fish would fit nicely because it looks
like honorable mentioned yeah we got to
give them some love I guess all right
all right I'm fine with that I you know
I remember that now here we can talk
about this top five topics ain't gonna
break the top four because Norman's not
on board sorry that's fine it's my
committee committee that's fine that's
fine I would say
I like the way this looks
I think this is a good job this is a
classic I mean you have to give credit
here's my only issue with take five
these two have stood the test of time
but you know what it's it's about
reinvention it's about
Lisa's was like I got new stuff right
sure you love the classic hour but you
want to see him do good new stuff what
you're saying why is it tell the Best
comedian of all Lenny Bruce George
yeah this is Madonna yeah Reinventing
Twix is yeah Twix is kind of like uh
Twix showed up and everyone was like No
One's Gonna top this yeah and it got
lazy it posted try doing cookies and
cream oh well have you done the
Hershey's cookies and cream though oh
that was awesome that's a [ __ ] bank
also we don't have like Crunch and
Hershey's Bars should be on it that's a
classic tip and I'd also say I'm back on
classic M M's recently they're good
they're very good yeah they they do you
have the peanut have you had the peanut
butter ones I love it anything peanut
butter I'm on board with I'll tell you
what's underrated is a [ __ ] you ever
have a crackle oh I love a crack
crackles great the bag of those those
little ones
never Mr good bar good bar yeah that's
the elite
Halloween candy yeah get a bag of that
mix yeah with the Mr Goodbar and the
Hershey bars the variety look he left he
got so mad at us
oh yeah sorry dude
I hope it's tasteful dead photo shoot
can I say that okay okay wait it's with
Deb yeah wait really yeah he's in New
York yeah oh yeah he's uh he's doing the
trial let's retrial him oh no don't come
on the bonfire talked about him for tell
him to come on
might be drunk I'm gonna tell him about
it I'm coming directly firmly but also
also let him know that we had a
podcaster in the pandemic called Sixth
and jump where we re-watched
that's a great idea but I would open
with we might be good yes yeah just let
him know but just let him know that the
bonfire is it's available on Sirius XM
channel 103 Monday through Friday and we
want to be drunk is available everywhere
so
also quote anything by Hunter S Thompson
and I'll love you oh dude also call him
the good doctor what does that mean you
like that he just called him a good
doctor tell him I think the rum diaries
was his best work it sucks and it was an
incomplete Hunter S Thompson novel how
they rep they published it after he died
all right we're all right happy
Halloween happy Halloween Dad this is
gonna break the internet this is gonna
be like Kanye and Tucker Carlson yeah
it's gonna be like Kanye and Pete yeah
all candy bars matter yeah yes now can
we get a a year what what year is
Snickers established or even Eminem or
Reese's you know what Eminem how Eminem
got paid
they put them a little bit in them for
because the Candy shell they could last
longer so they give them to the Troops
oh so they put them in their uh they're
patriotic
it is those Daddy really is freedom so
it's almost 100 years still go how long
Okay how long it's 90. I bet Eminem's as
long 92 years yes yes I see how long
it's gonna do that man yeah I get it I
am dumb original M Ms 41. 41. so
Snickers right now wow how about how
about a Hershey bar that's got to be the
longest that's gotta be That's All
American right there
Pennsylvania baby
oh that should be on the list do you
think out of respect we should add a
Hershey yeah but you know what though
that's like watching Lenny Bruce ah
you're like I know it did a lot for us
that's when I go back but there needs to
be a foundational piece yes yes I would
probably know bonuses Hershey bars I now
here's my question Clark Barr was 150
years 17 16
Reggie Jackson was the face of Clark
really really thank you baby
obviously I think how when was Reese's
Pete when was Reese's Peanut Butter Cup
because I I wonder if it's gonna be
older than we expect or younger than
it's gonna be later I'm thinking it's
like 60s 70s
oh God
1920s oh I was way off whoa It's older
than Snickers wow it beats Nick I mean
that's that almost spit yeah that is we
can't have we can't have Reese's in the
top too Rhys was a former employee of
Hershey and he broke away damn you gotta
love that then now there's friction
between you know oh man look is there a
good book on the candy bar Awards
there's gotta be oh we're about to write
one yeah we're about to sit around
eating candy getting fat and then right
up it's like a garage
all right well I think we got a hot list
here that's pretty good candy did we
lose did we miss anything else I mean
listen we can get into it because as
I've told you there's High shoes
Japanese Starbursts I would expect you
to say that dress is Yoshi no no
is Skittles even in the running I love
Skittles all right I will put Skittles
in my top five
wow how about sour skittles yeah it's
all Skittle what about Jolly ranch
those were better when you were a kid
because you could hide candy it was for
hiding in class green apple and
watermelon were dope though watermelon
watermelon Jolly Rancher [ __ ] slaps
very good when you infuse vodka with
Jolly Ranchers
like that I would also say like I mean
you could get fancy with the chocolate
you could go you know like Lind you ever
had a lint I don't know what a lint
l-i-n-d-t
Jeremy Lind
you should have came out with Lynn
should have came out with Jeremy
[ __ ] am I how do you say it Lind I don't
know I've just I've never read it before
but I'm a dove man myself God Dove
chocolate is unbelievable not this is
like this is one percent chocolate we're
talking yeah yeah right right we're
talking every man this is Bezos [ __ ]
yeah this is on a boat in the China City
we've never even heard it that's true
he's having Mars chocolate like actual
Mars chocolate he's having like cacao
healthy yes yes you know it's crazy this
actually makes me more ripped excuse me
muscle definition no one knows about
this yet no what is that circular gold
ball that candy that's the foreign
I can't believe we haven't mentioned I
think it's a classic the Butterfinger oh
oh that is a big love a Butterfinger
what about heaths I hate this salad
throw some Heath and coffee ice cream or
vanilla ice cream a [ __ ] chocolate
blizzard yeah or in a vanilla blizzard
come get it is it hard to break in like
have we invented a chocolate bar this is
what we're talking about boys you guys
are getting in the hooch game I know
let's get over to this [ __ ] sweet
treat you're right I'll tell you what
just use my mind hook up wires to it and
I'll I'll lay in a tub like Weird
Science yeah or like Minority Report
with the oracles I'll just lay in the
tub with other Stoners and yeah
delicious things you're laying in a tub
of eggnog
it's like a milkshake it's an old
vanilla let's let's try the payday just
so we do because I feel bad I think we
gotta if we're gonna trash it we have to
try well get ready for something that
was popular when Brown V board hit the
[ __ ]
yeah we should be in charge of abortion
I mean look what we can do this
is shitty it's like all peanuts look at
these and caramel candy bar
look at this
you know what this is the dog food this
is Schlitz beer candy is it that bad
like or he likes payday all right no
it's peanut butter and caramel I want to
try it
I haven't had this forever you feed a
horse when it wins when it loses we put
a wreath on it
it's not very good no but we don't know
what we're trashing yeah no you're right
yeah right I like that
all right wow I'm having a crash yeah
it's not good no dude I'm gonna have
cocaine energy on the bonfire
yeah what would that what remember that
one you lick and you dip it that was
[ __ ] fire it's better than it's you
remember it better than it actually it
was the number of pixie sticks
that was that was coke for kids yeah all
the kids you saw two in the pixie sticks
all are dead now coincidence
they went pixie sticks auto erotic
asphyxiation to the kids that would make
themselves pass out yeah I did that
remember that about that yeah those kids
now are just adding this to it
that's true that's great yeah I left the
kid with the biggest dick he's like
that's what they're offering the teacher
to suck his dick for a better grade
Peters
hell yeah you wanna
that is like I think when a kid pictures
coming feels like yeah
it's when you're [ __ ] all these
sounds when you're banging
and then when you juice too early it's
my favorite part oh that's the the gun
yeah don't burn out yeah that's like oh
you're so beautiful yeah
let me go down on you I'm so sorry I'm
so sorry you're so beautiful
I'm so sorry
it's the only compliment followed by an
apology
it is a compliment using early yeah or
the other one is like my reload time is
crazy you make the false promises give
me 30 minutes 30 minutes you always said
let's go on an episode of uh yeah now
that we're bearing down on 40 it really
becomes like a well that's all we got
yeah give me till Wednesday yeah you're
just an old sea camp in there
we're [ __ ] bazooka yeah one shot one
shot and if you don't take you're a
sniper right take a shot you missed you
can't start but you do learn Precision
yeah you do and to hold your breath
Mike I used to date this gal we kind of
had a thing and she was the only girl I
knew I'm not great in bed but if you put
it in she'd be like yeah and it was over
and you could just have your way it was
it was it was Heaven on Earth what Uncle
primed her
she was a soul cycle chick I remember so
I think the bike got her all primed up
all day and I got I got over there and
it was just that she's working the [ __ ]
then you come and you finish the job she
comes so easy like a cat in heat yeah
and I felt like what a girl must feel
like like oh geez you're done but the
beauty is women can just stay there is
that why women like cycling more than
men it's much more comfortable in the
vagina than it is in the balls oh
probably that's a great point my my
question is is like uh did she talk
dirty like it's Soul cycle or she's like
okay got a big one coming up I need you
to [ __ ] Mark I need you to fart and [ __ ]
yeah
now pick up the weights yeah let's go
don't need no man
let's go team who else is here
there's a big black guy waiting behind
me
let's get this going man I feel like
that's a good list I know we threw it
together fast solid Schindler's List
right here who are we saving
I don't yeah yeah I do feel bad but I
think Starburst is a classic I do feel
bad having it all the way up all right
you know what switch it with Twix that's
what I was thinking really I like that
Mark do you agree but you love Twix I
think Twix is a [ __ ] I would say Twix is
top five for me personally me too okay
I think Starburst just went against a
lot of good Big E schools and you know
what yes that is true Vicky Starburst
had a harder schedule yeah yeah okay
Twix is a [ __ ] classic oh you freeze
a Twix that's a good [ __ ] candy bar I
thought the Twix candy bar was
underrated too you know which one's
great that my girlfriend does what
Frozen Charleston chew I said that
before it's amazing oh you pull on them
they're [ __ ] Charleston
cocky though a little bit I guess when
they're when you freeze them yeah the
mini ones are bad [ __ ] you gotta
update your package that package is so
dated I love it it's [ __ ] yeah sweet
tart rope I'm gonna tell you right now
the best candy on the market it's hard
to find our sweet tart rope bites this
[ __ ] whoa I will siphon gas for you
that's heavy that's how good sweetheart
rope bites with the Rope well here's
what the rope lights are these are the
ropes sweet tart rope bites are little
ones that are then rolled in sour sugar
Jesus Christ
those those blue sweet tart rope bites
wow it's pure can we get Mac can we get
those next week I just want to try them
I'll tell you I'm gonna tell you where
they sell them LaGuardia Terminal C damn
that's a road dog right there
yeah you know the terminal airport candy
selection
we landed in uh Phoenix and Vito goes
this looks like a nice Shake Shack I'm
like we have such sad lives that's a
nice one a nice shot kill me but yeah if
you go to the big Market at LaGuardia
Terminal C the Delta you can get some
sweet tart rope bites because pretty
much they're off the shelves is it like
a real rope no it's just a little bite
oh okay and it's got the white chewy
[ __ ] surrounded by you know like uh tart
[ __ ] it's good damn I think Twizzlers
took a stab at this type of [ __ ] too
like the sound so did AirHeads and
AirHeads missed Big Time AirHeads back
in the day though as a banger I'm back
on AirHeads yeah
AirHeads is great this is a great sober
episode
I'd get the big bag for for Halloween
that you could because they're they're
the minis to you can I can I make a
point that's not popular I understand
we're in Halloween right now
Easter is the best candy holiday whoa
whoa I'm more of a Passover Man
Chocolate bro listen it's a it's a boys
day for candy no the eggs are phenomenal
really you're putting these eggs over
there any eggs Mini Eggs the Mini Eggs
Cadbury Mini Eggs what about Kinder Eggs
kinder eggs are all right now when
you're raspberry Mini Eggs I may be
better than anything I'm checking out at
CVS around Easter you best believe I'm
grabbing a mini egg the mini eggs are
almost full egg too I'll go full oh even
the bunny I like oh dude straight up
chocolate Dunkin Donut [ __ ] jelly
beans by the way or dog [ __ ] how are we
not all 400 pounds we've all tried this
oatmeal cream pies love them
they made it do you know they made an
oatmeal cream pie no no no cookies
cookies are fair it's a sweet there's
there's fluffer Nutter in there it's
okay that's a whole different list
oatmeal oatmeal cream pie which by the
way made famous in Honey I Shrunk the
Kids that's right when they find it and
feed the ant that that's how they
control the ant that's right for food
oatmeal cream pie we got covid Katie and
I got covered at the same time is this
the Utah Wise Guys covered yeah and we
did go puff that Mormon code yeah it's
that [ __ ] multiple wives yeah we get
covered and then you soak inside your
girlfriend you're like oh don't move we
go puffed because they would deliver to
your door wow and so we didn't have to
have contact with anybody go Puff
had for like
four days maybe five days oatmeal cream
made by Little Debbie Oatmeal cream pie
cereal it was uh [ __ ] awesome that's
a lot it was [ __ ] unbelievable little
were they they're like that big and they
were Airy so you get the water in there
oatmeal cream pie cereal you're not
gonna find it on Amazon it's not
available
I think they pulled it from the market
whoa probably gonna give me cancer
LaGuardia Airport
that's too much oh
there it is oh you guys mind if I do
this real quick
on the subway right the Yoshi jerk offer
yeah yeah first up all right guys can I
tell you guys what I'm really into it's
Yoshi jerk off play
I catch my own [ __ ]
we're in the Delta lounge and they have
the you know they have chocolate chip
cookies I'm almost like I know chocolate
chip cookies are good but it's like
almost two I've had too many right so I
see a white chocolate macadamia my
[ __ ] nipples get hurt
but you get a [ __ ] oatmeal cookie in
there it's oh not raisins
I love an oatmeal raisin um
chocolate chip and you're and it's also
Stolen Valor what do you mean what do
you mean oh cause you're like you're
getting people from afar being like I
might be an oatmeal chocolate chip
cookie I'll [ __ ] go all day it's like
a trans person yeah like oh I know what
this is wait a minute
by what it's called yeah well it's
already in my mouth
dude you taking that red eye flight
there's something really sad a bit of
red eye we just want to get back oh yeah
we're in that red eye and uh we're just
pounding desserts in the lounge and
Veterans doing that thing where he's
like are you gonna have another I'm like
I'll do it we're gonna do this after the
Saturday show after the Sunday what so
we took it uh why I just want to get
back so it was a seven 7 P.M show we
take the 11 p.m back I'm impressed so
dude I I do the last chop right I do the
uh upgrade I'm trying to get the upgrade
to first class and I'm I'm in line and
there's this has never happened to me
before but there's a guy trying to get
on he's trying to buy the last first
class ticket and they're like so you
have to wait we have to see if him
buying it go through and he had a bit of
a language uh difficulty and I think it
saved me getting that first class seat
bro all right immigrants
hell yeah I think he was like they were
like sir it won't go through and he's
like okay
shutting the door was it a Spanish I
wasn't paying attention I think he was
French but I did a Spanish guy yeah
because I don't know Sam just wanted to
do an US versus them
I said you know what yeah maybe they're
taking no jobs because they're not
taking our seats brother that's a good
win that's a very good win
you know he didn't get on uh he didn't
get on the flight it was great oh it was
a great moment where she was like sir it
won't it won't go through and I was like
and Veterans like did you get it I was
like oh my God you got it then you're
like get to the bathroom I mean it was
seriously between three people you're
28b no no where are you guys on this
because I know you're an animal guy well
yeah you love animals my dog is one of
my favorite things on this Earth okay
well let's go get dicey because I was
just on a plane and I noticed I looked
on the seat map and I said ooh five A's
open I'm taking it so I took 5A and
moved me way up from like 22b sure get
to 5A there's a lady there nice little
lady German Shepherd no service dog yeah
is sitting between the seats is the
service dog an actual service dog where
she blind nothing no I don't I think it
was an anxiety here's why I don't like
that I have a dog our dog probably
weighs 50 pounds she's a mutt
she stays at home yes or driving she
came on the road okay is it leaking over
in your seat of course yeah that dog a
German Shepherd's too big for a plane it
did the thing where he put his head on
my my thighs that was cute but I'm like
you're in my area and I'm like it should
be in your area why is it in my area did
I ever tell you how much I love dogs
that uh we were on the Impractical
Jokers Cruise right and Jay and I and
Christine uh bought an ounce of weed and
got it on the boat and we like had spent
the whole night rolling joints and
putting it in a cigarette pack and we
get it in
and the first night we smoke weed
everything's fine I have a half a joint
and a bunch of white chocolate macadamia
cookies that I got from the [ __ ] uh
you know the kitchen or whatever and I
had that's what I had in my room and I
fell asleep watching the carbonara
effect or whatever it's called because
that's all they play is Impractical
Jokers or whatever yeah so I leave it on
the desk
I go to sleep we dock in the Bahamas
uh-huh I wake up to the sound of a dog
and my first reaction is like oh right
someone brought a dog on this thing yeah
and it was a drug dog oh
and got right up to my door and started
scratching and I got in trouble I didn't
get like kicked off or anything but I
got in trouble they took the cookies
they took the wheat there was no weed in
the cookies yeah these are legal because
there's a weed cookies no it wasn't it
was a regular cookie it was weed in
regular cookies there's a shitty drug
dogs you're like we're taking these too
but they did I mean I got in trouble
because the apparently the half a joint
smelled enough that this dog got it whoa
but I love dogs so much that I was like
my first reaction was like dogs and then
I was like why are they searching what
are they drug sniffing dogs and there
was a lot of people that got in trouble
oh they could have been Midnight Express
for you dude I should have jumped over
the side if it was like uh Sal's in the
back going go into soda's room
okay okay now ask where the cookies are
from
yeah oh I don't know well the drug the
dog is man's best friend until it's drug
sniffing yeah then it flips you know the
prick yes he turns on you but dogs on
airplanes man it that's like uh and if
you're moving I get it there's
situations where I understand it but
most of the time you're like leave your
dog at home yeah there's all these
studies now that or get someone to you
know watch it or for trauma though if
you just pet dogs it stimulates brain
activity it's like really good for you I
get it Jersey dance age remains joke
about he got sober and he's like I knew
I was in trouble because they were in a
field teaching me how to pet a horse
he was about to kiss a woman and some
homeless guy he was like don't kiss him
don't do it
it's cold he has one about getting on an
elevator with a little girl and uh like
two flights in she goes I don't like him
holding a pizza and then he leaves and
she goes I'm glad he's gone
I'm glad he's gone he's like I wasn't
even doing anything I was holding pizza
followed Daniel either Dan Saint Jermain
or Daniel St Germaine DSG yeah D.S
Jermaine yeah of course he is a [ __ ]
he's weird yeah
Russell roast is a great if you're into
wrestling hilarious podcast where they
just roast wrestlers but he's a great
yeah Mike Lawrence yeah Lawrence and
Scott Chaplin they got a girl I love
those guys yeah yeah Saint germain's
great I had to sleep in the same bed
with him once uh in a in a Comedy Fest
which you know I love the guy we've
known each other but you know the lights
go out and he's just quiet and he's like
you ever kill a guy
come on we got it we got into an Uber in
Tacoma we were going to a dispensary in
Tacoma we got in the Uber and uh
immediately Saint Germain just goes hey
what's up with that Green River Killer
and it just looked like the guy was like
oh yeah I'm like dude this isn't the
conversation
he's one of those sweet guys who knows
way too much about True Crime oh yeah
it's great he's dark he's the [ __ ]
man I love dancing he's the man yeah
he's such a great great comedian man I
know I know he's at the cellar every now
and then I see him but yeah who knows I
think he's writing for stuff but yeah
all right we got the list we got we
tackled Mario I think we we're good yeah
do you have any peeves oh yeah bits or
anything oh yeah the three things I
forgot my phone
um what name the three things I remember
what it was pet peeve pet peeve is
people who comfortably FaceTime in
public oh great one if I can't see you
react with a little Grimace of like I
know I know yes no headset even yeah
just loud
I know yeah look I'll be walking my dog
and I'll see people just FaceTiming and
I'm like I'm hearing your whole
conversation yeah it doesn't bother you
hey Steve I had a guy doing a flight
next to me once no headphones and and
his voice got like louder right yeah I
like that it's like crazy when you're
just you should at least be like hey
what's up yes that's all we ask that's
for the phone voice in celebration I
don't know what it is you put me on
speaker I'm like yeah I'm right here
but Pepe he was
um no remorse public FaceTime great
people love it love it why is a phone
call that's not great either but it's
still way more respectable than like a
FaceTime you know why because the
FaceTime they're gonna see if I'm like
in line behind someone they're seeing me
uh whoever they're talking that's crazy
I don't know
have you noticed that those those people
always get pissed off that you're like
hearing their conversation yeah that's
why like you're in my world as well no
way it's like you you're doing this to
me right you know why it's shittier than
a phone call it's because it's a
combination of talking on the phone and
texting yeah because you're not you're
not looking live and you're [ __ ] on
the phone so you're looking at the phone
and it's you have no none of your senses
right right you're walking well that's
it good point
don't like it all right good good piece
I got a peeve I gotta pee for you I was
in line in the moons uh last night this
person's asking 100 [ __ ] questions
about the food and I was like there
should be a separate line for people who
have questions and then a line for
people who know what the [ __ ] they're
doing totally there should be a novice
line and a pro line yeah because that's
also the thing I loved about becoming
living in New York and learning how it
worked it was over time when we lived
here that I could walk into a deli and
be like
a sandwich bacon egg and cheese plain
bagel boom I'm over to the side yeah I
got it paid for I got my milk paid for
my chocolate milk I'm good to go well
the city has a rhythm and when you're
going up there well what does that one
taste like and how much for that one
you're breaking the whole system it
makes me think of that recipe bit where
he's like I try to get a pizza bagel
because I was hungry and the lady said
uh what happened
well I'll tell you what happened I woke
up in my apartment and I was hungry and
I came here for a pizza bagel he's been
quoted on this podcast
recommendation I'm not finished with the
book but I'm reading a classic that's so
good why hasn't anyone told me this book
East of Eden by John Steinbeck oh yeah I
don't know it is for what I never did
actually you would like it Steinbeck's a
beast what a good man [ __ ] book it's
thick but it's like I'm halfway through
and I'm like I enjoy when I start
reading it really it's very rare yeah
it's just about like about these two
brothers and this [ __ ] psychopath
lady and that's where I'm at and one of
them married her and the other one
[ __ ] her it's [ __ ] crazy
like a fiction book like but that's
what's crazy is Steinbeck's like this is
like he's like this is my best one but
he's also got Grapes of Wrath this is
like our specials for them yeah right
they have mice of men too Of Mice and
Men he's very short got the Pearl he's
got like that Charlie he's got so many
good books he's got a lot of good ones
too but East of Eden that's the one I'm
reading right now the one all the way to
the left from Amazon I bought it and uh
it's [ __ ] great yeah why what made
you buy it
um there was a quote that I you know
like uh I was I saw a quote somewhere
where it was like I don't need to be
perfect so now I can be good and I was
like oh I like that and I was like
what's that from East Eden and I love
Steinbeck and I was like you're never
ready Stevens I ordered it Amazon it
shows up the next day started reading it
I was like this is [ __ ] good I love
it being a classic too you're like we're
like well even if I don't love it I'm
gonna be glad I did it yeah yes yes so
true but I love to hear a quote and
you're like that grabbed me yeah exactly
the whole book and that you know I think
we live in the age right now where
everyone acts perfect and everyone acts
like I'm there's too many goats
everyone's calling everyone a goat goat
you can't goat means one the greatest of
all times you can't be I saw someone put
out a tweet where they're like a podcast
with a couple future goats and you're
like that's that's incorrect makes sense
that is incorrect but only one of them
can be the goat only one of you well now
it's turned into uh yeah when people say
a few of the goats right yeah I've been
saying on stage it's like the way that
right-wing people right-wing people use
the word Patriot the way hot girls use
the word literally
I think you're just using that because
it makes you feel good at this point yes
yes exactly literally I'm like I believe
it happened right and America and then
right like hard writers are like I'm a
Patriots yeah I got it yeah someone
anytime someone uh texts me like an
American flag Emoji I'm just like on
Rogan I said how much that bugged me
whenever someone will send me an
American flag Emoji or like when they
have that in there there's something
about the just flags that bug me oh and
uh and now everyone tweets flags
and I'm like it's pretty good yeah
you're like I walked into that one yeah
I deserved it but you got a lot of range
I mean this guy can jerk off as Yoshi
and eat his own come and read Steinbeck
Wow Let's Go what a
catchers
there you go
[Music]
this one's a little bit more General but
I can't stand when people watch me eat
when someone's not eating and I'm eating
and they're like boy you're really uh
you're really inhaling that thing yeah
boy hey look you like Mayo on there
really if you go Mayo do you go to gas
stations and talk about how they pump
their cars yeah exactly
that's unleaded you're right you're
eating a burger like the Tomato comes
out yeah you lost that tomato
it's an intimate thing to be eating it's
very annoying if someone it's like
literally it's like one step away if
someone commenting on you [ __ ] you're
totally yeah right that's you feeding
right so it's like I don't watch me feed
yeah and there's those weird little
moments where you like get a little
ketchup over here like oh [ __ ] and I see
all that it's too much it's too intimate
yeah Bobby Kelly was on the bonfire
yesterday oh he eats who knows now he
looks great oh okay he lost like 50
pounds well I think he lost her over
that over yeah and he looks great follow
him up Jay and I Jay and I got pizza in
between our shows and we were eating and
and uh Bobby's like see this is why I'm
a good friend Jay you got something in
your beard I'm like it just happened
it just happened he might have caught
that's what you're a bad friend you're
eating pizza in front of a guy who's
clearly on a diet yeah no yeah that was
probably the main part but look at him
that's he looks good oh he looks totally
different yeah leaving the face looks
different no thank God great thank God
he got in there
he has new special by the way is awesome
it's on Louis C kill box it's called
killbox Louis ck.com uh but he wow Bobby
got into the rotating door with me as a
joke oh really we got through I went
Bobby I'm so proud of you yeah don't
ever do that again all right but I'm so
proud of you for doing it wow he looks
days like Brando and uh holy [ __ ] he
does it
holy [ __ ] holy [ __ ] oh my God what is
this the Freshman
he looks so good dude I'm so proud of
Bobby dude good for him and we'll let
him on it I mean does anyone kill like
Bobby like the laughs and the worst
bananas one of the worst experiences
comedically of my life was I ran my hour
before HBO at Edinburgh at Edinburgh uh
at The Fringe Festival
and then went to Vegas to do the seller
Vegas we're out there for a bachelor
party and I was like I'll stay and and
work the weekend
and Bobby was taping Netflix's
degenerates oh wow and Liz put me after
Bobby every night wow of him running his
degenerates so it's not like his TV
clean and you yeah he's filthy and he's
filthy and it changed the hardest follow
there is is a is a filthy killer that's
true and it was dude it was like I would
go up there and you just felt the room
you know how you can feel it you know
where you can feel it crackling like a
fire has been put out oh yeah and
everything's yeah I dude I bombed four
shows and then you know Bobby's like you
[ __ ] [ __ ] what you can't follow me
yeah and Liz is like you [ __ ] schmuck
you stink and the whole time I was like
this is
brutal dude wow you gotta love that
about Liz she's the manager of the
seller yeah for those at home but we'll
get her on for Bobby's we should get her
on she's she's loses the [ __ ] but she
never changed like the seller has
changed a little it's gotten like more
inclusive and all that but like Liz is
still like I'm gonna be a hard-nosed
[ __ ] till the end I love it I don't give
a [ __ ] but when you win her over when
you win her over oh she's the best and
she's the most loyal person on the
planet yeah she will just trash you all
day but if there was ever a jam yeah
she's got you I didn't oh yeah like she
helped me I did like uh you know after
you tape a special you're like what do I
I'm supposed to do something I taped
special in New York so I was like I'll
have a after party and she like was like
do it at the fat black I'll help you
we'll do this and she like organized it
and I was like this is so easy yeah I've
taped multiple things at the seller you
know like albums specials and she
organized it all yeah we do live
bonfires every Christmas because of her
she's the best and it's crazy I mean
it's like you know when you see like a
show there'll be that character who's
like really nice but is full of [ __ ]
yeah yeah she's the mean one who
actually is a heart attack that's
exactly so true where you're like is
this person mean and then you're like oh
no she's the best person yeah it's
unbelievable it's part of the it's part
of the vibe but it keeps the seller the
seller Liz Liz keeps the seller yes
you're a little scared of her in a good
way and the new people being afraid of
her I like it yeah shut the [ __ ] up yeah
she never takes a day off never they
better be paying her well because she
could be making I don't think I asked
her once she was like we need to we need
to do a podcast and a patreon and then
just give that money to Liz yeah like
this is for you keeping the Integrity of
the seller the seller is the seller
because of Liz absolutely agree veter
did his album in Vegas only so he could
call it veto Las Vegas it was literally
the only reason in Vegas but we all went
out there we like you know supported he
filmed like 10 20 minutes oh that was
the weekend what that was the weekend I
was out there oh really did we see you
no cause you guys came Thursday Friday
you guys were like Wednesday Thursday
yeah yeah because I came out Friday
Saturday oh okay well it was Ari it was
list it was fun and vecchione and Liz is
out there every night watching veter
with a clipboard and going like okay
that joke killed and she did all the
legwork and she loved it it was like a
spreadsheet it was she's one of those
people that needs to be doing [ __ ] yeah
yeah and I I like one of us has got to
make her an executive producer of
something so she can have [ __ ] off money
now you're talking yeah someone needs to
put her if you're another comic watching
this and you know Liz and you have a big
TV show coming up give her a producer
credit so she can have [ __ ] you money
the sad thing though is she got too much
money she might leave the seller yeah
which we need her there too sure it's
kind of a tough ah how do we keep her in
Dentures yeah
yes yes no she once told me even if she
was like hit it Filthy Rich she would
still like work for like the Dania Beach
in Providence
she's like I need I need the stimulation
she's one of those people that you know
those people that like they can't retire
yeah because the second they retire
they'll drop dead yeah it's like Paterno
the second he had to stop working he
[ __ ] died and she used to watch me
shower and I used to [ __ ] kids
you'll believe that so YouTube doesn't
pull this uh
[Laughter]
[Music]
plug some dates yeah I got Nashville
Zanies coming up I got Philly helium
coming up I got uh when is this coming
out Halloween October yes or November
and December I've got uh Zanies I've got
uh oh Comedy Castle marker at least
Comedy Castle club and um and Philly
helium also two shows Bell house uh in
December and Brooklyn gonna have a very
fun show that's going to be Saturday I
believe December 20th hell yeah Bell
House New York and uh Dan St germain's
gonna be there gonna have some other
friends come through and he literally or
micro scene there you yeah oh nice oh
looking good there
I mean uh senior brain just text you
yeah oh did it really yeah so there it
is
drunk in a tub and his name is Nashville
Comedy Castle and Houston Improv never
done it oh that's a great one yeah
December 1st through the third and then
Bell House in New York December 10th
love it uh two shows at the Bell House
Philly helium after that maybe a liquor
partner Chris Hart will go see you yeah
go see him look at that all right I'm
all over the road uh this comes out
later you gotta hit that puppy there
uh [ __ ] up doing Houston as well uh the
joy theater New Orleans The Wilburn
Beantown New Haven uh more Wilbur
Fillmore and Philly Buffalo helium
that's gonna be a tough slug Toronto
again
always one two Cubs never done it never
done it no I'm excited have fun and then
I'll see you back at the punch line oh
damn it's the same owners all right
Nashville uh Hawaii that'll be
interesting a lot of fun dates uh come
on out got a lot of stuff coming down
Brunswick OKC Springfield Missouri Fort
Wayne Kansas City Tacoma Spokane
theater tour just went on sale starting
in January that's uh New Orleans Austin
Dallas Tulsa Missouri uh St Louis
Missouri Vegas Vancouver Seattle
Portland Salt Lake City Huntington AC
Royal Oak Minneapolis Madison Milwaukee
New Haven Boston Miami Orlando
Jacksonville Atlanta Charleston Durham
Virginia Charlottesville DC Wilkes bar
and Port Chester hell yeah samrail.com
shows get [ __ ] tickets now
yeah we love you and by Bodega
catwhiskey.com and uh patreon watch all
of our specials got a great HBO special
son for Gary his Netflix half he's got
Comedy Central special watch HBO
no you're HBO now one of the best New
York Mormons I'm sure we're gonna tape
something soon yeah out to lunch check
that out get the bodega same time
tomorrow Netflix get a shirt yeah yeah
watch Sam's Netflix special praise Allah
anything to plug you still say less if
anybody needs I just started my own
little Consulting Agency for bars or
restaurants so paper plan NYC there you
go for all your Barn restaurant needs
and check out Gotham videos yeah and if
you got a problem with this list tweet
about it start your own chain let's get
the internet cooking thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we might be true
[Music]